steve bannon is the former white house
chief strategist he's also the host of
the war room and as we just told you
he's just been convicted of two crimes
steve bannon thanks so much for coming
on i you you can't kind of help but
notice that you were convicted of a
crime which is not actually a crime most
the time in washington or ever
within the same 24-hour period as a guy
who tried to murder a gubernatorial
candidate in new york was released with
no bail what are we to make
of these two events occurring the same
day
well as you can tell the democrats are
completely lawless and look how they've
run this committee there's no ranking
member there's no minority council it's
not like the traditional hearings that
have galvanized the nation the past and
tucker i think it's one of the reasons
that it hasn't really had that big an
impact you know when they they
interviewed the people on the trial i
think almost all the working-class
people didn't even know what was going
on your show with people like darren
beatty and revolver and rohingya you've
done actually more original reporting on
what we've got to get to the bottom two
look we need a commission or committee
on january 6. it's got to be with the
new congress with republicans in charge
we've got to get to the bottom of the
intelligence failures fbi involvement
dhs involvement the intelligence
services what happened to the pentagon
in the national guard all of this all
ashley babbitt all of this had we have
to get to the bottom of it and people
are going to get to the bottom of it
even to the fact of some of the
testimony that was given by staffers uh
in in mile trial you know we wanted
decision makers to come over and
actually go on record uh under oath and
say exactly what happened here and they
would they hid behind a privilege of
which they wouldn't allow which they
wouldn't allow me to the the the judge
the time narra cast us on the executive
privilege issue
i i've spent my whole life in washington
i see a lot of acrimonious debates but
the idea you would send someone to
prison because you don't like his
political views there's no allegation
that you organized january 6th that were
there a storm in the cabinet doesn't get
fully insane they don't like your
politics
they hate your attitude and they're
trying to send you to jail did you think
this i didn't think this could happen
we'll start there did you think this
could happen
a hundred percent i think it happened
this is the remember these guys all
thought they were going to change china
and the chinese communist party they're
taking on the aspects of the
authoritarian state and state capitalism
combined this is the the elites that run
this country this is exactly what how
they want to run it remember tucker i'm
not new to this i i've spent more than
any trump official in intense uh you
know uh
being a witness in the molar commission
for i think 30 hours uh in the house
intelligence committee the senate
intelligence committee i had bill burke
i had alex spiro here i had david shawn
i had top lawyers they wouldn't even let
my they wouldn't even let it be that i
could rely on the uh on the opinion of
my lawyer here they took away every
possible defense so somebody can have a
defensive law okay that's why we didn't
even put on the defense we just had a
closing had an opening argument a
closing argument tucker this is where
they're going i mean you document it
better than anybody but no people have
to understand this is just one fight in
an entire process and that's why it's
absolutely incumbent that liz cheney's
defeated in a couple of weeks in wyoming
by the republican party and by
conservatives and buy mega and then
later we've already got kinser out we've
got another member of the committee i
think is already retired we got to
defeat lauria but we must have a
sweeping victory in the house and then
republicans have to have the stones to
put on a real hearing and by the way let
the democrats have a ranking member let
them have a counsel and just get to it
if you look at what darren beatty's done
on your show alone it's outrageous what
the public doesn't know about this we
for the good of the system this has to
happen
but in the meantime
you've just been convicted
i mean if the how do you feel about
going to jail are you confident you
would be safe there for example
first off if i go to jail i go to jail i
will never back off a second look i
spent eight years as a naval officer
i've committed my life to this pro to
this program to get this done i will
never back off i support trump in the
constitution and i'm not backing off one
inch if i go to jail so be it but look
we've got a long appeals process andy
mccarthy did a great hit on fox earlier
today we got a long appeals process i
think the law is with us on a number of
situations i think some of this is
really going to be adjudicated maybe
even higher than the appellate courts i
i'm very confident that we're 100 right
on the law but i'm going to fight this
all the way and this is not the only
battle we're fighting they're coming at
us on every aspect look they're trying
to shut you down they're trying to throw
off fox anchors they're coming for
everybody and people have to understand
right now this is an ideological war and
we cannot lose the the the fate of the
country is over the next couple of years
and if people just want to go on
vacation and say hey i'll just let get
sorted out that's fine but there are
just thousands and thousands and
thousands of fighters out there to say
we're not going to back down one inch
and i'm not going to back down one inch
at all
did you think during the course of this
trial maybe you should call eric holder
and lois lerner both of whom live in
washington and just say like how did you
beat this like what what's the secret
sauce here
the secret sauce is then they're in
power and also let's be honest the
republicans have been controlled
opposition that's what has to change
that's for sure this november not only
do i have to we have to deliver a
crushing blow to this democratic party
apparatus but then we have to really
govern it i mean govern on offense every
committee in the house has to be an
oversight committee we have to go after
the biden administration which is
illegitimate you can tell they're
illegitimate look how the saudis mock us
to our face look how the chinese
communist party have absolutely no
respect they understand he's
illegitimate we have to get in there in
january every committee is going to be
an oversight committee and we have to
have a real january 6 committee
including to get to the staffers now and
see about the lies and
misrepresentations they put on national
television to the famed people you're
gonna i would tell the january 6 staff
right now preserve your documents
because there's going to be a real
committee and this is going to be backed
by republican grassroots voters and
magnets say we want to get to the bottom
of this for the good of the nation we
have to know everything that went on all
the intelligence reports exactly what
went on what was ray's involvement what
was fbi asset involvement i mean just
stuff look just just go to revolver and
see darren beatty on your specials and
when he's on your when he's on uh you're
the tucker carlson show right there
alone leads you to all types of inquiry
we have to get to the bottom two
yeah
if you know republicans win and mitch
mcconnell is still running the senate
you've got to wonder like is it is it
even worth it uh but i'll let you and
the political guys uh fight that better
steve bennett i appreciate your coming
on tonight of all nights
thanks very much good luck thanks tucker
appreciate it thanks brother
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight